the idea of a two-state solution in my
view is unrealistic the Palestinians
have always rejected every compromise
based on two-state proposals under the
British a appeal commission 1937 the
United Nations General Assembly 1947
Clinton Barack 2000 they've always
rejected the idea of a Jewish State
alongside an Arab state in a partitioned
Palestine and they continue essentially
in their hearts to believe the Zionist
Enterprise is a robber Enterprise and
Israel is a robber State and they refuse
to accept its legitimacy and so long
that is their mindset they will not
agree to partitioning Palestine into two
states in addition to that Israel has
moved to the right the Israel settlement
Enterprise has blossomed essentially
taking over the land in the West Bank
which would be part of a Palestinian
Arab state were there to be a two-state
settlement